leader McCarthy led us in passing
legislation to secure our borders keep
our nation safe and the devastating
practice of sanctuary cities and yes
madam clerk build the wall and
congresswoman Cheney joins us live from
Capitol Hill tonight good evening the
equivalent of some it's good to have you
tonight you were speaking for Kevin
McCarthy knowing full well he was
unlikely to get the votes to become
speaker but is now obviously the
minority leader this was Nancy Pelosi's
day she told NBC that the president
doesn't know how to deal with a powerful
woman were you surprised by that comment
and what is your party's approach now to
her as Speaker you know in my experience
powerful women ought to be concerned
about the security of the nation and the
fact that you know we're still playing
these political games when we absolutely
have got to secure the border we're
seeing thousands of people come across
that border attempt to come across the
border illegally significant increases
and the numbers who are attempting to do
that in the last 48 hours or so we've
seen attacks on our border guards on the
southern border we've got to secure the
border and so I think you know this
really at this point is about keeping
women secure keeping men secure and
doing what's right for the country and
the speaker I understand that she was
hesitant to move forward on this until
she secured the votes on the floor she's
done that now and we really hope for the
sake of the country that the Democrats
will stop playing these political games
the president made that case in the
White House briefing room a short time
ago let's take a quick listen I have
never had so much support as I have in
the last week over my stance for border
security without a very force strong
form of barrier call it what you will
but without a wall you cannot have
border security we've never had more
people wanting to come to the United
States and that has to do with the
economy and has to do with a lot of
other things where we're doing great as
a country it seemed like a forceful case
from the commander in chief but you
helped craft the Republican Party
message were you surprised that White
House officials didn't get the president
out there sooner for the last couple of
weeks yet Nancy Pelosi in Hawaii and
you've had Republicans like Karl Rove
saying why isn't the president using the
bully pulpit look I think the president
has been you
the bully pulpit I think that it's
impossible to be confused at this point
about the fact that the president wants
to secure the border anybody who is
confused is just not listening I don't
think the president could have been any
clearer in terms of how important is the
American people don't want to see these
games they don't want to see a situation
where 25 percent of our government is
shut down
you know the appropriations bills that
the Democrats are putting on the floor
today include things like stripping out
all of the protections the Mexico City
so-called Mexico City protections that
protect life that prevent us taxpayer
money from being used to support
international aid programs that would
allow abortion so of course we are not
going to support that and the Democrats
again it's it's political partisanship
and games the American people are sick
of it and frankly they want to see the
border secure so we're going to continue
to work to fight for that I was pleased
to see leader McConnell make clear that
you know the Democrats right now are
just on a fool's errand to try to make a
statement while we we put the security
of the nation at risk and I think that's
untenable you say Democrats are playing
games take a list and do a sampling of
what some Democrats have said just in
the last 24 to 48 hours so cut your head
off and you won't even know you're
bleeding that's all you need to know
about her much like Hitler took over the
Nazi Party Trump has taken over the
Republican Party my new year's
resolution is to make sure that the
Republican Party drives on top of all of
that you have the the speaker telling
NBC yesterday no no no there'll be no
wall on top of all that rhetoric what do
you make of all this
I think they ought to keep talking
because I think the more the American
people see how radical and how out of
touch the Democrats are the more they're
going to regret the fact that the
Democrats are now in control of the
house representatives you know we face
huge challenges in this country huge
challenges from a national security
perspective and we've got this this
economy that's booming because President
Trump put policies in place like the tax
cuts working with us in the Republican
side of the house like regulatory reform
rolling back the strangling regulations
we saw during the Obama era we got to
keep that going and I think the more the
Democrats are out there sounding is
radical and frankly socialist as many of
their members especially some of their
incoming members are the better it is
for the Republicans and the better it is
for the country because people will see
the choice that they've got to make in
2020 and then
to get back to actually accomplishing
things for the nation not on the far
left fringe of politics
congresswoman Liz Cheney a leader a
Republican leader in the new house we
appreciate you coming in tonight thanks
for having me good to be with you